our next guest stars in the highly
anticipated new movie Babylon with Brad
Pitt and Margot Robbie Mexican actor
Diego calva plays Manny Torres a young
Hollywood executive it's a breakout
performance for him he previously acted
in the Netflix series narcos Mexico
Babylon is set in the 1920s and shows
Hollywood's transitioned from silent
films to movies with sound in this clip
Calvin's character Manny is getting into
his Groove as a producer and making a
movie with his love interest Nelly who
was played by Margot Robbie
[Music]
hey move that microphone 45 degrees okay
okay
okay
yeah okay okay okay
let's roll people let's go take two
the beautiful chaos of Babylon Diego
Calvin joins us first on CBS mornings
good morning thank you for joining us
Diego how you doing
good thank you I'm so happy to be here
thanks of course now uh Damien chazelle
who wrote and directed the film wanted
to bring someone new to Hollywood and he
chose you how did this role change your
life
well uh I still have to see you know
um the movie's going to Premiere in
December and every day just full of new
experiences and I just grateful with
Damien because he already changed my
life
so Damien listen let me just tell you
this was a wild ride a couple of times I
was watching the screen going what is
happening here but I I think you have a
very fun character to play seriously all
the different things you get to do did
you relate to Manny in any way what what
was your process in preparing for this
character
well Damian gave me a lot of time I
prefer I worked a lot in my English I
worked with a dialect coach I work with
a acting coach and we rehearsed a lot
and yeah I I find my many like
similarities between money and me money
is still my best friend I've met him all
day now
all of us are dreamers I think I I knew
very young that I wanted to dedicate
myself something related to movies and I
tried a lot of different ways I started
see film Direction I work as a boom
operator as a catering the same as my
character I was just trying trying to
find a way to to be invited to this
beautiful party that is Hollywood a
beautiful part in San Diego this kind of
sounds like a dream come true for you
then I mean listen you're with Margot
Robbie and you're with Brad Pitt in the
same movie good company and Toby McGuire
exactly Gene Smart the cast is really
Stellar does it feel like a dream come
true to you
every day in the morning I still have to
pinch myself and talk to the mirror and
realize this is happening you know like
this is real life this is actually going
on so yeah it is a dream come true
well here's a dream like question for
you Diego uh Brad Pitt your co-star in
this movie apparently gave you some
advice on set I'm curious what was that
advice
there was one day when I was like
struggling with a scene
um Brad came to me and he just said like
Diego you have to protect your craft
that's what we the only thing we actors
have you know like our craft and you
have to make decisions and trust your
instinct and when you take a decision
you have to go all the way with it don't
hesitate and I mean any advice coming
from Brad Pitt is beautiful but uh yeah
she's really helping me that day you
know
you've had uh you say some uh you've
mentioned earlier you're still living
with Manny Manny's your best friend your
character there uh you embody him so
well you say that part of the way you
related to him is that you've actually
in the rise to fame had some Manny
moments some Manny experiences uh could
you tell us about those
well I think my character and me we also
are related because from one day to
another you know I was living in Mexico
City downtown Mexico City and two weeks
after I was like meeting Margot Robbie
and talking one-on-one with Brad Pitt
like that guy you know like different
situations yeah and I still have that
kind of situations every day you know
every time I meet a new celebrity yeah
it's like I play it cool you know like
oh yeah my name is
another like exciting moment that I have
to pretend that I'm so cool but uh
honestly I feel like a cute all the time
oh God what a great feeling me you never
lose that you know the Golden Globe
nominations just came out Manny I mean
Manny Diego that's his characters
yeah I know I'm having a Manny moment
the Golden Globe nominations just came
out a few minutes ago and guess who's
nominated for best actor in a motion
picture comedy or musical do you want to
tell them Nate it's Diego calva Bravo
[Applause]
[Laughter]
alternated Marcos nominant go you Manny
so tell us what does this feel like now
Mr calva what does it feel like you were
nominated for a Golden Globe
wow uh I don't have a speech
wow I just want to congratulate everyone
that watching the movie because this is
uh wow it's a so special feeling right
now but I think that it was a teamwork
you know it was a hard movie it was a
beautiful movie the man just changed my
life they mean if you're looking at me
right now thank you man thank you really
it's all human it's on you Damien no no
no Diego we thank you and right before
we went on we were watching you as you
were getting ready and you were saying
does my hair look okay we want to tell
you your hair looks great you did a
great job in this movie congratulations
Bravo to you this is very exciting wow
it's so good to be here on this day for
you
what what a special moment not being in
live TV for the first time and being
nominated
it's just too much
it's too much but it's well deserved
Diego Calvert thank you so much Babylon
will be released on December 23rd by
Paramount Pictures which like CBS is
part of Paramount global